seven point game approaching two to play
Butler with a long shot
Jimmy Butler just came to free 17 for
him Austin has coach I got to ask you do
they come back and go to that zone
this offensive rebound Martin Robinson
for the tie
Smart's got it four point game left
seven minutes ago
[Applause]
Butler catches his way inside
Butler will defend Tatum shot pocket
Ford Tatum inside
rostered
Robinson for the lead
rebound Tatum out to smart
[Applause]
knocked away Robinson on the drive by
smart Butler has scored 10 of the last
12 points for Miami
defended by Horford
[Music]
will pick it up
well there's a lot of to unpack here on
this play by Jimmy Butler certainly
there's contact in the foul by Al
Horford it was called a two on the floor
but look at the feet of Butler clearly
in my opinion he's behind the
three-point line this should be three
clear throws but there was also behind
the three-point line at the time
[Music]
they've gone on a 13-4-1 since with 11
of the 13 by Butler
[Applause]
to time
after two most important ones out
here it is right here
and Gabe Vincent's trying to tell
everyone to calm it down
three seconds on the clock time out each
way
Dave Butler hits
it's a Heat lead of one
[Applause]
foreign
the Boston five and Coach you view these
scenarios in every practice you go over
these with three seconds or less
[Applause]
and they're gonna have Matt screws face
the floor here but he's got to be aware
of Derek white on a quick pass back also
white will inbound
[Applause]
[Music]
it'll be reviewed
I don't think he got that in time great
effort by Derek life and didn't I say
you have their saying on the floor
they're counting it you have to protect
the offensive rebound oh he got rid of
it
the Celtics are gonna win there's a game
seven back in Boston early on the floor
is good basket the plays under review
White
what a finish to this game
stunned people here are absolutely
stunned a rush shot that went in and out
by the way by Marcus Smart that's what
allowed Derek white the offensive
rebounding opportunity bucket good we're
headed to beontown for a game seven and
what has been an improbable Eastern
Conference Final
and Boston becomes the fourth team ever
down three games tonight to force a game
seven the first one of those teams to
get a shot to complete it at home the
other three were on the road
[Applause]
white got it game-winning basket
white finishes with 11 let's go to Ali
lafour